برلمان الاردن يوصي بطرد سفيره اسرائيل
بعد ازمه الخريطه
متهمه ترامب تسخر منه وصور تحاكي اعتقاله
تثير ضجه
اجاده واسعه بفريق طبي وصل اجراء عمليه
اثناء زلزال
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
بعد ازمه الخريطه وتصريحات العنصريه التي
ادلى بها وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي
قبل ايام صوت اغلبيه اعضاء مجلس النواب
الاردني بالموافقه على مقترح بطرد السفير
الاسرائيلي من الاردن رئيس مجلس النواب
احمد صفدي طالب الحكومه باجراءات فاعله
ومؤثره تجاه استخدام خريطه ما يسمى بارض
اسرائيل والتي تضم حدود المملكه الاردنيه
والاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله فضلا عن
اطلاقه تصريحات انكر فيها وجود شعبه
فلسطين او ثقافه فلسطينيه وهو ما اثار
موجه انتقادات وادانات عربيه وامريكيه
واوروبيه
في الازمه الروسيه الاوكرانيه حتى نائب
وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
على تجنب التصعيد في اوكرانيا قائلا ان
امريكا متورطه فعلا بشكل مباشر في النزاع
عبر تزويد كاذب باسلحه المسؤول الروسي حذر
ايضا واشنطن من اختبار صبر موسكو مشددا
على ان الاخيره ستاخذ كل الاجراءات التي
تضمن امنها بكل الوسائل فيما اكدت
المتحدثه باسم خارجيه روسيه ماريا زخرفه
ان عزم بريطانيا على تزويد كاذب بقذائف
اليورانيوم والمستنفذ يعد مؤشرا واضحا على
سعي الغرب لتدمير اوكرانيا تماما
بالتزامن مع انتظار الامريكيين قرار محكمه
من هاتنا الجنائيه الذي من المتوقع ان
يصدر قريبا باحتمال توجيه اتهام الى
دونالد ترامب وادانته اثارت متهمته ستور
ميدانيا الجدلا واسعا بتصريحات جديده ففي
تغريدات ساخره على حسابها في تويتر ردا
على احد متابعيها كشفت انها سترقص في
الشارع في حال اذنك ودخل السجن ما اكار
موته انتقادات ضدها من قبل محبي الرئيس
الجمهوري فيما لاقت صور للحظه اعتقال
ترامض الجواسعه في السوشيال ميديا ليتبين
لاحقا انه جرى تصميمها بواسطه الذكاء
اشاده واسعه بما فعلوه انتشر على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي فيديو لفريق طبي
باكستاني يجري عمليه جراحيه اثناء الزلزال
الذي ضرب البلاد الليله الماضيه الفيديو
الذي انتشر واسعا ظهر فيه الفريق الطبي
وهو يجري العمليه ثم انقطعت الكهرباء لكنه
ظل ثابتا ومستمرا في عمله حتى عاد التيار
الكهربائي مره اخرى عبر المولدات
الاحتياطيه وكان زلزال بقوه 6.8 درجات ضرب
اجزاء واسعه من باكستان لمده 30 ثانيه على
الاقل واسفر عن سقوط قتلى واصابه العشرات
في خبرنا الاخير اعلن لاعب المنتخب
الالماني السابق مسعود اوزيل اعتزاله لعبه
كره القدم عن عمر ال 34 عاما وبعد ان نشر
بيانا على حساباته عبر مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي قال اوزيل انه وبعد دراسه
متانيه اعلنوا تقاعد الفوري من لعبه كره
القدم الاحترافيه مضيفا حظيت بامتياز ان
اكون لاعبا لما يقرب من 17 عاما واشعر
بالامتنان الشديد لهذه الفرصه وتابع اوزيل
مؤخرا وبعد التعرض لبعض الاصابات اصبح من
الواضح اكثر فاكثر ان الوقت قد حان لترك
اللعبه